you'll begin to see the world with  greater Clarity things start to make  some kind of sense once you realize and  accept two points about the elites who  run this country  um our Bettors as they see themselves  anyway one is that they hate you and  everything you stand for and everything  you believe this cannot be stressed  enough it's not a very pleasant thing to  think about but it's the truth it  shouldn't be a Breaking News Bulletin  either I mean after all they're not  exactly trying to hide it they despise  you your family your ancestors on down  the line the second point is that they  are both uh Petty and creative so  they'll take advantage of every  opportunity to humiliate and demoralize  you and they'll see such opportunities  in situations that wouldn't have even  occurred to you